what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today we're
talking over coffee that i always say
i'm gonna quit
i never do um before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification
bell the way you're gonna be notified of
my daily videos so
i'm gonna give you guys just like
thoughts that i have about like society
and one of those thoughts
is inspired by as you guys know
a friend of 20 years said she couldn't
be friends with me anymore based on
something i posted did a video on that
yesterday if you're interested go go
watch it
but
i was thinking how weird it is we have
access to so many people's opinions now
like people had
people act like we've gotten so so much
more divisive in this day and age but i
don't even think it's that i think
people have always been opinionated
but now we have access to them
so now i can look up
if you're liberal if you're conservative
just based on who you follow on
instagram
that's kind of crazy
and then so then i got to thinking a
little bit more right
and i was thinking so i'm playing
volleyball in the uk right now
and
my bet one of my best friends here like
my best friend here
we agree on nothing
like nothing we are polar opposites but
i swear to god this girl is the most
supportive girl i've ever been in my
life like she's my biggest cheerleader
but we agree on nothing
like literally nothing and i was
wondering like why and the rest of the
girls they're they're pretty much like
from california l.a they
very very left-leaning and i've been
really open about the fact that i'm
conservative here and i'm not normally
because people usually assume i'm
liberal just based on like talking to me
um but here i've just been really open
about it because
i don't know i just
i don't want there to be any surprises
later
so for example um a boy
i'm not gonna tell this full story but
there was some shady stuff going on with
another girl
and i knew he was like with her because
i saw on her story that she was at like
the trump hotel and that's where he used
to take me long long story okay
but
i kind of would make this joke when i
told this story to my friends because
i'd be like
this is even more offensive because i'm
a republican
you could take her to any five-star
hotel but the trump tower
i was offended okay i was i was i was
very
it was just like salt in the wound you
know what i mean but okay that's besides
the point very open about it so when i
came here
i assumed i'd make no friends
but i'm like actually so happy here and
i love the girls like i love him to
death and what i realized is like
if you're nice to people
they don't really care
like if you come up and you're like fun
and you're nice
sometimes they probably wish i'd talk
less i'm gonna be honest
that's my fatal flaw but now i have you
guys to listen to me
but like the majority of people have
their opinions but they haven't really
thought them through and they're not
that opinionated
and the majority of people don't have
the balls to be mean to you in real life
so they might think those things about
you
and that's what i was thinking with my
friend
and it makes me really sad actually like
it's a really sad situation but
you know i can't i'm not gonna beg
someone to be my friend you know you
know what i mean but
like it made me think that i think if we
weren't so far apart
like i don't i don't think it would be
like this
but
it's just like weird because the
internet
gives people i i think a true view of
you but also warped
because that you get access to
information that you in other words
would have
no access to so like if i played
volleyball like you know 50 years ago
i would have no idea what the political
opinions were of my teammates they would
have no idea what mine were and we
probably would never talk about it
because why would we
i mean maybe as we became like good
friends we would but like on a
superficial level but now i'm in this
position where people just like know
what my opinions are and sometimes it's
very like
weird to have all these people that like
don't know me like they know me on some
level and
nothing and a lot of people will say the
internet gives you a false view of
people but which i don't think it's true
i think you really get to see what
they're passionate about because that's
what you post about that's what i post
about [ __ ] i'm passionate about
so
yeah daily thought for today i think i'm
going to keep doing these so if you like
these let me know in the comments it
really helps boost me in the algorithm
so like please leave a comment if you
can and i will talk to you guys next
time